your what's watch list just got a bit
longer we've got the shows that will
have you hunkering down for the holidays
welcome everybody to Entertainment
Tonight all right let's start with a
brand new special from the queen of
Christmas Mariah Carey
[Applause]
[Music]
costumes and the drama and all the
things like we're bringing it for them
but like really for me it's the spirit
Mariah shut down Madison Square Garden
performing all her hits before a sold
out crowd a special treat she pulled
daughter Monroe onto the stage to
perform
[Music]
I said to my daughter the other day I
was like who do you think likes
Christmas more me or you guys and she
was like
I don't think we can choose that the
event is being turned into a two-hour
special Mariah Carey Merry Christmas to
all which years tonight on CBS in
Paramount plus but Mimi's got a bone to
pick with us all about the holiday
never called myself
the queen of Christmas can we please be
clear
on that and to self-proclaimed Grandma I
might really I'm gonna do that they can
look up every interview I've ever done
and not to get super religious but I was
like I think like if anybody would be
the queen of Christmas that would be
Mary and then and then somebody else is
uses my quote against me
[Music]
despite that Mariah's holiday hit is
still topping the Billboard Hot 100
chart for the fourth year in a row it's
made her a reported 72 million dollars
to date although she dropped this
surprising fact we actually make on
streams 1 16 of a penny on every stream
so I can't do the math if a
scientologists upstairs I'm sorry a
scientist
or the scientologists
[Music]
actual snow so I really froze my little
self to death for my fans even before
dropping her massive hit Mariah was
already spreading holiday cheer E.T was
with the star in 1992 where she belted
out some classic hits with kids
here if I can give something back to
people for everything that I have then
it's the least I can do it makes my
Christmas all I want for Christmas is
you was the first Christmas song that I
ever wrote and we just wanted to make it
feel like a modern classic
you know there are very few people in
the world who Embrace being a diva but
Mariah loves them oh yes
yes that's why we love her so while Mimi
prepares for Christmas in New York Lily
Collins has given us more Emily in Paris
Season Three is out tomorrow and the
cast is dishing on all the drama and the
love triangles in the city of love to
our Deidre Behar
maybe the pressure is not worth it it's
definitely worth it it's your dream
you teased that there was going to be
like a shocking amount of Cliffhangers
in Emily in Paris season 3 and man did
you deliver my goodness I heard all the
endings and thought they were like alts
then I realized they were all the
endings at one this is the hardest
decision I've ever had to make romance
work and life in Paris season three will
be a roller coaster but let's talk about
team Gabriel versus Team Alfie Emily's
complicated love life has even the cast
torn on who she should choose I just
want her to be happy she doesn't she
deserves to be happy
Alfie is super clear he's super Charming
but he is very grounded and he's like I
know what I want so Cooper
where's your head at
you changed my life
she's in love with Gabriel deeply I do
think you can love with as much
intensity
more than one person Emily no Emily's
bestie Mindy finds herself in her very
own love triangle too as for Emily's
bosses
I just need to know are you on my team
or not I'm so in on team whatever this
company's called your friends and
colleagues in real life but on the show
you're at each other's throats what is
that like for fun
it's really um it's and it's definitely
fun to play it would not be a very
interesting show if we're both like you
look great no you look great I love your
work I love your work and you know we
had to ask about the rumors of this
Cameo you said that you'd love for Kim
Cattrall to come in and play Antoine's
mistress who shows up at the Emily in
Paris Premiere Kim cattrell so now we're
all wondering was that foreshadowing
this is what is called manifestation
is there a role that you you think God
she would just crush it in that in that
spot I think just an icon in some way
yeah coming in or herself
the door's always open for him of course
season three's fashion delivers Emily
pushing the office dress code in shorts
and a gold trench Mindy performing in a
mugler bodysuit like Dua Lipa and don't
get me started on this fabulous pink
feathered coat in real life the cast
also held nothing back at the premiere
this is unbelievable can you tell me a
secret about this dress well getting
into it was quite difficult there are
zippers and clips and clasps but once it
gets on it's like a second skin
it's Valentino the secret of the dress
is that I love the jacket
you didn't come to play with this purple
suit listen live at home called and it
was just it made sense it made sense
you are strategically covered in all the
right places can you tell me a secret
about this dress
the secret about this dress is I had to
have about three people get me into it
it fits perfectly it's comfortable it's
warm which is great and I love my boots
also coming to Netflix The Witcher blood
origin this prequel to Henry cavill's
series stars Michelle yo and Minnie
Driver I need you to sing a story back
to life when something is a franchise
you need to to keep making it
interesting I think it was very smart of
them to
have someone as unexpected as me enter
this universe the four-part mini-series
drops Christmas Day and tells the story
of how the worlds of monsters men and
elves merged into one there'll be no
coming back
well now let's get to the return of John
Krasinski as Jack Ryan season three of
the Prime video series is out tomorrow
and clearly this cast is ready for
anything right here together guys
looking good you kids get to watch Jack
Ryan or their projects that they can see
they think I'm an accountant they think
that uh they think that Mary Poppins
married an accountant do you really
think so and I think they think that
Emily was very sweet to marry this like
kind of
neonormal dude but this is far from
normal season three sees Jack Ryan go
Rogue
what's the craziest stunt that you think
you got to do this season in the trailer
you see me get thrown out of a Blackhawk
one of the Navy Seals who consults with
us he said it would be a lot cooler if
you did the stunt and I said I I don't
even know how that would go and he says
how it would go as if I unbuckled your
seatbelt and threw you out of this
helicopter right now and then he did oh
boy that's in the television show and
you can see in my face that I am very
very real scared all Eight Episodes drop
tomorrow on Prime video what are you
doing improvising this time Jack's
accused of treason and on the run to
stop a World War you're about to cross
the line and there may be no going back
because I'm trying to do the right thing
he's joined by Michael Kelly Wendell
Pierce every second Madison and
newcomers to the series Nina Haas and
Betty Gabriel three words that best
describe this new season
intense surprising bra the toss I like
that for Goodwood gravitas action
espionage
entry that bass lightning okay badass
lightning yeah well we raised the stakes
every way possible is that that's three
words right every way possible there you
go
we waited a long time for this new
season so glad it's here
[Music]
talk about an All-Star lineup for our
home for the holidays the special is now
in its 24th year and it celebrates
families whose lives have been changed
through adoption from Foster Care it
airs Friday on CBS it's one of my
favorite shows of the year and I I
always cry I'll be honest I always cry
tears of joy though your heart's really
full after you watch that for sure
meanwhile Paul Simon fans we know what
you'll be doing tomorrow night watching
Homeward Bound at Grammy salute to Paul
Simon on CBS our Cassie Delora was on
the red carpet so everybody a man who
means the world to me and to the whole
world of music Paul Simon
the Jonas Brothers you guys just
performed out there
[Music]
how did it feel I hear a lot of artists
are very nervous to take the stage
tonight
um yeah I mean it's nerve-wracking
obviously one of our Idols
um someone that we've grown up listening
to we didn't see him before him but we
saw him while we were on stage went down
and gave him a high five and uh it was
good he whispered don't screw this up I
didn't say that
they just killed it they just killed 50
Ways which would be I guess 150 Ways in
their case but yeah I mean they're and
and it says it all that all these genres
come together because he's influenced us
all
would you say he his music has impacted
your own throughout your career
um well you think about like phrasing
because of him you think about could
Paul Simon pull that off could does that
feel natural to sing that
and and somehow he's done things that no
one else could get away with
[Music]
Garth Brooks and Trisha Yearwood
Oprah the Joe Bros and sting are just a
few of the celebs who came out to honor
Paul in the two-hour special back when I
was in college I was obsessed with Paul
Simon I well I still am I don't want to
admit it to him but he's sitting right
there
I had to look over Woody I like I saw
him and he smiled and then I was like I
can't I can't concentrate
I heard you guys were here so I wanted
to just come check check it out that's
Black Adam star Noah centineo as he
surprised fans in advance of his new
action series the recruit I love your
jacket enjoy the train yeah
you got to meet some fans today
they're right here
I don't know you got a really sweet
jacket did you get to yeah she got my
jagging player you're a real one look
better on her anyway is there a problem
[Music]
oh there's so many in Netflix's new
eight episode series streaming now Noah
plays a CIA lawyer caught in an
international power struggle you could
really kick some butt but booty kicking
and I get my butt kicked as well it's
the Spy genre right it's thrilling
suspenseful it's badass it's a little
bit of drama but we're following a young
kid that has no idea what he's doing but
he's intelligent he's competent he's
just inexperienced he
he's all right
now to the holiday gift that all the
fans of the best man franchise have been
waiting for the best man the final
chapters hits peacock in just two days
y'all and it is that good I sat down
with the cast for one Epic reunion it's
gonna be just like old times
only better right better do you feel the
the push from the folks out there that
still want a little messiness between
you two I think we're gonna give them a
little messy it's always going to be
messy right that's how life is life is
always right now I mean always messy I
took that as Nia Long's not so subtle
nod to the headlines about her ex-fiance
email adoka cheating on her but her
Focus In This Moment a not safe for work
scene involving co-star Morris Chestnut
was there a sock involved or tape what
was it because when I watched the
trailer I'm like oh my God exactly no
but when I touched it it was like
of course ET was first on onset with the
crew back in 2013 for the best man
holiday where we learn what really went
down behind the scenes the last time I
went to his trailer he had a light on
his forehead and some type of scientist
suit it was kind of like The Nutty
Professor was coming out the trailer the
conversations that go on are so racy and
inappropriate that it's just it's like
coming to school and hanging out with
your friends from college I mean we were
just laughing constantly cutting up
always dancing
in between takes are you making your
booty clap wow please let me see
sometimes they're like can you please
settle down can you please stop laughing
nearly a decade later nothing has
changed silly funny so much fun every
day what I will say is we have had a
ball everything comes full circle and we
can put a bow on that me and the guys
not one of us in 25 years have ever had
an argument the best man the final
chapter is eight episode series hits
peacock Thursday but how would these
friends do with a quiz about others
previous films Titan's and I weren't
brown sugar what was the line to Define
their relationship I love you baby I'm
what was it what an actress she just
said something when did you fall in love
with hip-hop wow go ahead see I like her
as a partners
when did you fall in love with hip-hop
loving basketball Monica was her baby
sister it's enough
what was
a character's name what's your
character's name do you know
what is it Lisa yeah
me and Morris were in a movie together
everybody knows boys in the hood do you
remember her character's name
Elsa
was Morris
but I'm bad with names oh
but I remember every moment when you
like
when it
did I do that oh it's so good
[Music]